[Wind blowing] [Car horn]
[Elevator beep]
[Music]
Hello!
My goodness, how are you?
So if you clap, you're capturing
the sound signature of the space
Hi puppy, hi honey
Hey everyone, I'm Cassie and I have an idea for you--
Wouldn't it be crazy if we made the
third floor Atrium into a theme park?
[cheers]
[Wind blowing]
...that has the appropriate properties, so we can pretty much add as many as we want, we can remove some,
[growling]
this will automatically [unintelligible] like if we remove like nineteen, the audio, you'll see it should be [crosstalk]
Hi, you miss me?
[Music] Okay, this is external sub, okay, no low frequency
Thank you dog
[Elevator beep]
[Wind blowing]
Oh my God, this is so cold! Nightmare!
[Machine noises]